I'm ready for this we already done
climbing
right now we're at stronghold bouldering
we're about to do some rock climbing or
bouldering nobody else was around except
for Ryan and Shane so I'm here as a test
guest or a guest E if you will I've
climbed a whole bunch of ladders whole
bunch of stairs vertical ascension
pretty good at it I don't know about
this though we're also trying to see who
could climb the wall the fastest I see
Jordan right there behind camera if I
could beat her I'll be happy because
she's a Megatron I don't think I'm
scared of heights I'll find out when I
get to the top the boys are already
gonna hurt themselves behind you you
frying these your legs as much as you
can you're gonna get the most strength
from your legs we all forget that a lot
the few things gonna do the best here
Gumby Xena or me it's hard to not get a
weird nickname me okay dopey dopey
they're better they're get his legs
bridgeable I don't know where my little
feet are going if he jumps you can
probably grab that way
this isn't various spiderlings
he needs to get a high handicap Murano
girl right and I need a height handicap
I worked very hard to be this tall
what I get how'd I do I mean it stopped
you in 1946 when you were right around
there 1946 I be changed
well Brian like like my mom my dad
helping me I get to this moment right
Shane and Jordan for being inferior
gonna try the hardest up old everyone or
one of the harder ones what's gonna good
yeah and it's gonna end poorly
that was great it was a lot of fun this
is definitely something I could see
myself doing in the future right now my
forearms and my hands are very tired I
get about as well as I expected you know
I succeeded on a few of them and then
the other ones I just fell off and you
know sometimes it's a choice I'm kind of
pissed that Ryan was so naturally good
at this cuz I really wanted to beat him
today but I'm also glad that he may be
found a new calling this is something
that I would do probably multiple time
to be because you just you're just
climbing [ __ ] it's fun
you